Wednesday night on Bravo it is the
season finale of The Real Housewives of
New York City and Kevin the real drama
is whether or not this will be Bethenny
Frankel's last show ever well as you
know Nancy she left once before in 2010
so here's the big question is she coming
back next season or is she gone for good
our Lauren Zima asked her straight out
as Bethenny opened up the doors to our
amazing estate in the Hamptons we are
here at the house that Skinnygirl built
it even has a red door of course in this
sprawling Bridgehampton home red is the
color of success five bedroom three and
a half baths all spread across almost
4,000 square feet where she escapes with
her daughter Bryn I'm just happy here I
feel I'm more suburban than city I think
that New York is where I work in here is
where I really live
Bethenny paid around two million dollars
for the home and she is very choosy
about who gets to hang there it maybe
takes a lot to make this wall because
I'm only seeing Bryn cookie Andy like
this is this feels like it's very much
very special people close to you yeah
this is a personal this is definitely a
personal wall these are good moments
just my favorites this season fans of
Bravo's the Real Housewives of New York
City got a tiny taste of Bethenny's
country home but only et got the full
tour no one else besides et has been up
here by the line really yep upstairs
it's cozy and very pink
thanks to her six year old daughter's
bedroom and who knew this millionaire
housewife is crafty this is all her
original clothes so this was her first
put one of her first pairs of pajamas
this was her first baby blanket another
one of her first baby blankets one of
her first t-shirts instead of getting
rid of clothes I sewed them into a quilt
and gala tea is definitely her style
everything in this house is a bargain
item I I mean I think that this this was
probably $50 the chandelier was a
hundred not a bargain item in this house
next up the backyard complete with a
pool and a bar so this is the yes bar
stocked with plenty of Skinnygirl of
course while the newest product is the
Skinnygirl watermelon lime margarita and
I keep the bottles in the wine
Christina Aguilera has partied till 5:00
in the morning here I've had Jamie
Foxx's like his posse came here and they
all were dancing to bel Biv DeVoe
anything but a party this week is the
finale for The Real Housewives of New
York City and Bethenny tells LuAnn her
fiance cheated on her and then all hell
breaks loose Bethenny just sent me the
picture Tom you have no recollection
what is what does that mean you were so
waste you don't remember how can you do
this where are you in LuAnn out right
now today um LuAnn and I are nowhere
today and I guess we really weren't that
many you really weren't anywhere when we
started the season
then there's the upcoming three-part
reunion special the reunion was
definitely not fun and all of my reality
television experience I've never been
caught in a lie I live my life honestly
and something happens the reunion that
questioned my integrity and I took it
really seriously okay so we might not
see you back you might not see me back
you